what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch the mandalorian season two
episode seven today of course looking
forward to it
if you enjoyed this video please hit
that like button subscribe click that
notification bell full length reaction
watch alongs where you sync it with the
time code will be available over at our
patreon page for the mandalorian this
qualifies as reaction highlights over at
our patreon we got a weekly q a podcast
we also do
many tv show reactions where at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along
included thank you to everyone who's
joined our patreon just in the last
couple months alone it means a lot
rick famous now whatever
you say he's directed this episode and
bill burr's mayfield is supposed to
return as well
that's my son grogu's my son
who's the mother yoda yoda's a woman
misgendering her all the time
he directed that one too right i think i
think so i mean he definitely did first
season
i believe he rick family directed this
one
oh wow it's like an imperial junkyard
the chopping fields it's so weird how he
blends so well into this world
this droid sounds like jeremy irons
damn polish
he's got some polished armor yeah
damn it looks like it's been restored
and detailed
and there's only her second day on the
job that was a long time ago all right
but you still haven't that's right
there's an imperial sharpshooter
not a storm trooper
you don't want to just keep working in
the junkyard do you
the believer kathleen kennedy forgot to
announce there's a mayfell show coming
too that's right yeah
mayfield comedy series we need
coordinates from off gideon's cruiser
yeah forget it there's nothing on morak
it's a secret imperial mining hub okay
if you can get me in there hmm
whoa sounds dangerous
punch in the coordinates that's so cool
wonder what they were finding in there
looks like rydonia
highly volatile ah it's a fuel
and like uh clone wars and rebels and
i'm sure
other parts too so we go in quiet
let's go get a closer look i don't know
i don't got a good feeling about going
quiet the slave one is a lot bigger on
the inside it's the tardis of the star
wars
as much as i'd like to take a road trip
with rebel dropper here that's not gonna
work these remnant bases are set up and
run by xisb
be sure to know a lot about imperial
remnants of course he does
no i'm wanted by the isb i'll trip the
alarm too
let's just say they might recognize my
face
so unless you're going to take off that
helmet it's going to be me going in
alone oh say goodbye to your little
green friend
oh my god is he going to take off his
helmet he's going to take off his health
he's going to do it i'm coming with you
oh
pedro
gloves is still wet ew yeah i must get
swampy in those
things oh look at this
oh the shade
is worth the price of ignition oh the
shame he got such a sunny disposition
i can't imagine how much fun you are in
one of these
hey how does it feel huh
come on man you still got to wear a
helmet right
i can't see anything
i don't know how you people wear those
things yes
feels better when it's off
he just really wants to see his face
shouldn't he put his helmet back on you
would think so
whoa but these are plebians
empire new republic it's all the same to
these people look if you're born on
mandalore you believe one thing if
you're born on alderaan you believe
something else neither one of them exist
anymore
wait a minute mandalore doesn't he you
said you couldn't take your helmet off
and now you've got a storm trooper one
on so what's the rule
you can't take off your mandolin you
can't show your face because there is a
difference
but i just let him be himself
here and poke holes in as many things as
you can
everybody's got their lines they don't
cross until things get messy dude he's
totally taking off his helmet
has been destroyed
i like this oh
god
it's like they're walked into a
guerrilla war zone i love that
it's also like train wrestlers yeah
this stormtrooper can shoot a blast
yeah it's like you're driving a big gas
truck my dude
oh
no he doesn't have his best car
cue everyone on insta learning how to
throw javelin now
i don't think fast is a good idea
oh my goodness oh nice nice
oh dude yes
yes mando
it's good
great stunts in this episode
no no no
oh god oh
[ __ ]
hello
there's some great ass shots
oh man the stunt work that was awesome
oh
oh my god i had so much fun so much
thermal detonators
oh here's where you can lose them
she's trying to use the force or
something
tie fighters back up
nice
wow look at that smoke
it's so weird to be like stormtroopers
to the rescue
makes sense though
that the signs look very familiar
the boss wants to meet you both to give
you medals
oh no they're going to lose sight of
their own identity yeah
they're going to get way too deep
here they're the best stormtroopers ever
your aim is so good where'd you learn
that you teach all of us
rogue one that's the stormtrooper outfit
uh from the like beach scenes yeah
yeah like the coastal something or
another
yeah tropical one oh no
no it's gonna be like a two tino the
right thing
i can't go in there i was just a field
operative but i'm not taking the chance
it's over
let's just do this quick but we can get
out of here give me the data stick it's
not going to work
that's richard break
terminal has to scan your face
dude take it off give it to me oh my god
he's gonna do it he's gonna
do it i mean i know he's seen it before
but still
he's gonna do it they've been teasing it
this whole episode
yes so nervous like going on a date
just play cool play cool dude
oh there's gonna be a translation on new
rock stars for that
paper just gonna go running in there
what do you look like yeah i told you
wow this is way longer than the first
season that you've seen his
that is facebook break huh pay attention
when the superior addresses you
oh god yeah designation it's absolutely
richard break
transport crew whoa
my designation is transport co-pilot oh
so
i can't believe we're seeing him talk my
commanding officer tk593
oh no he's seen his face yeah i'm afraid
you're gonna have to speak up to him a
little bit since his vessel lost
pressure in tina
huh that man what's your name
come on let's go fill out those tps
reports so we can go recharge the power
coils you're not dismissed
dude richard break is so scary he's so
good at that like
disaffected sinister troopers have
delivered the shipment of the redone him
yes sir yes sir oh my god there's so
much pedro pass no i can't get over
come with me
let's get it drink
brown eyes
is he gonna keep his helmet off the
whole time oh that's how much he
loves grogu you concentrate on the
troopers
i'll take the cannons girls get it
to done or to success
[ __ ] he's gonna recognize him yeah sums
up here
how about a toast to operation cinder i
lived
oh i was in burning cotton i had to make
many unpleasant decisions
yes you did oh oh oh entire city gone in
moments along with everybody in it we
lost our whole division that day man i
was like five ten thousand people
all heroes of the empire yeah
i don't know well it's a small sacrifice
for the greater goods
depends on who you ask don't you think
don't let them get too provoked was it
good for them died defending their homes
fighting for freedom was it good for
them
but we've outlasted them son they're
eating themselves alive
son of a [ __ ] you see with the
rhodonium you've delivered
we can create havoc that's gonna make
burning con just pale
by comparison son of a [ __ ] then
they're gonna turn to us once again
oh no he's gonna snap
everybody thinks they want freedom but
what they
really want is order
they're going to welcome us back with
open arms
be careful guys i'm so worried
he's going to do something together to
the empire
to the empire
not good not good
i never saw your face oh
oh [ __ ] oh god
this is a great position to be in guys
cool nice cover on my way whoa
now we gotta polish that that ship up
oh my god
i love how they really gave a soul to
his character
seriously give me that cycle right there
was it that tuscan raider gun
yeah nice shot
y'all need to sleep at night
oh no
he's doing the jingle
oh cool thank you for helping
yeah did i look okay that was some nice
shooting back there oh you saw that yeah
that uh that wasn't uh part of the plan
but yeah
i was just getting some stuff off my
chest
emotional day no it's too bad mayfield
didn't make it out alive back then
yeah too bad we're leaving it here on
the planet
where he's gonna be hunting we're gonna
kill you ourselves
three four six six seven died in the
refinery explosion on morack
third day on the job kara third day
you get the coordinates i'm off gideon
we did
awesome what's our next move murder his
ass
take the fight to him
dude he's throwing the line back
at him
oh we got to put him in a movie quotes
or something challenge
remember oh he wrote it too not bad
that was so cool he threw his leg
through his own lines back at him
gotta love it man gotta love it they did
the uh that seismic blast
yeah he would jacob's fighting uh ob was
saving from obi-wan and tackle clones
i mean he like kind of did a lot awesome
richard break
he's killing it doing his richard break
who would have thought a scene between
richard break and bill burr would be
freaking awesome and intense don't worry
they'll star in the next rob zombie
movie together
you know i love is that he directed an
episode of the last season
that was like super duper contained
atmospheric
and that was the breakout episode right
with the one with bill burr
and then here it's just so expansive and
big and in the jungles what i love is a
for the directors that have come back to
direct for this season
they have done something completely
different than what they did in the
prior one and i think that's really cool
that way you're not just
finding it repetitive i love that i
thought i thought he killed it on this
one
absolutely yo these tools been killing
it lately
[ __ ] they really have been my
goodness absolutely back to back to back
it is non-stop
goodies this one was great
like another fantastic one they brought
back bill burr's mayfield and they
really gave him
character development he can just come
across like
a bad guy a prisoner just looking out
for himself but then when he's telling
that story
to the valentes character you can just
feel this pain he looks like he's on the
verge
of not just rage but tears as well you
feel there's like pathos he brought to
the role oh man i'm starting to look at
this guy in a completely different light
i mean just the fact he didn't abandon
the mission that when he saw denjaran
was caught in a sticky situation with
his helmet off and didn't know how to
lie his way out he just got in there
right away
to help out he didn't try to run away he
didn't abandon he went in there to help
out and then it turns into like what you
were predicting like a tarantino-esque
type of scene you're a pretty big fan of
richard i know you are yeah
i mean he's an amazing character actor
and they really used him like he's the
exact kind of character actor right now
you want to be one of these
slimy imperial officers he's got just
that
drawl almost like he doesn't even care
about what he's talking about because
he's just that confident in what he's
saying and yeah he
just can show up and not even start
speaking and already have me
unsettled and i thought they used him to
great effect here i mean
it was cool to get another like imperial
security bureau officer
thrown in here and boy did he deliver
just that
sliminess and it just makes it feel that
much more
lived in when you when you don't just
hear them giving orders or taking orders
you really get to get an insight into
their mindset on things
yeah what would this guy toast to and
what would you want to keep alive in the
memory of our greatest battles or our
greatest days or whatever like that
whole back and forth about their history
was
a great scene emotionally because you
know he's throwing it away he's like ah
but we're bigger than ever we're doing
great
completely missing all of the emotion
coming out of billboard like such a
great yeah
just emotionally played yes like how
we've pointed out on pretty much every
discussion
every episode if not every most episodes
present themselves with something
where dinjarin has to challenge
his mandalorian beliefs his religion as
opposed to the first season where it was
very much
sticking true hardcore intensely
at all times as much as he could and
while he hasn't like abandoned his
religion
every episode has lent itself to
something else to change up the rules as
mayfield is even talking with him in the
car it seemed really obvious that at
some point he's gonna take his helmet
off this episode
they're talking about it so damn much
that it feels like it's gonna come
and that they they gave purpose to it
because he has to save
grogu he loves he loves that little baby
yoda so much
he has to save him and desperate times
call for desperate measures it's like he
did it just like i just have to do it
there's no choice
yeah and there was so much more of
seeing paige
it's like it's so jarring you're just
like damn
right pedro pascal's on screen after
pascal's my free time was on screen i'm
like
he's on screen right now like my my mind
just can't get lost in it really there
it is just like he's really there
it's not just a cameo scene like it was
in the in the season finale of of uh the
first season being here
like this is a full scene here his face
is showing
and it really enhances like the stakes
the discomfort the personal
strangeness of the moment for dinjaran
like you know it was a great way i
thought to keep us
bonded to him in that moment and to
create a very palpable sense of tension
yes even just them having a little
argument
trying to convince mayfield to go and do
his part of the agreement yeah
so much he has so much great great
tension played through the both of them
and i love when he's just standing there
awkwardly going along
with what they felt is feeding him
pretending to be definitely
half the time like getting some subtle
uh uh you know not
jokey but performance body language
based humor and and discomfort with
dinjar and i thought was a cool facet of
this too you know i'm not mistaken i
don't think we hear him speak
without the mask on he says yes sir once
no i'm saying in the first season
oh but but here right he's got like a
couple of lines he's like wow
we're watching him speak without the
mask no distortion this is crazy
yeah this is so weird i don't believe
those rumors and other some youtubers
who
really do think that's true i don't
believe them about
uh pedro pascal not now like leaving the
show or wanting to jump ship because of
not seeing his face i
for some reason i'm just not buying that
rumor well not buying that belief or
leak or whatever but
you know it was seeing that here i don't
know if it's gonna get turned into
yeah he fought to have this because i'm
like no this works so integral to the
scene of the story
it's the tension and that's part of the
theme yeah it's not
just some pedro pascal had this shoe
horn in there
yeah if it's a vanity moment it it fit
perfectly indeed
you know we're great some great writers
they got here yeah
yeah and i mean i love the overall film
style they brought to this too because
you know i feel like it's a meme of
mandalorian reviews now to touch on like
oh
western and samurai film style but i
really loved the elements of
just the action scene that erupted when
they're driving the huge you know
uh juggernaut tanker you have these like
you know
natives to the planet that are like
fight like i love pirates
yeah the pirate like i love that sense
of perspective and it even comes back
when
mayfield is talking to hess that sort of
like was your operation good for
these people defending their homes for
the lives of your soldiers and their
families and like
driving through that scene almost felt
like a legitimate
instance of that because and also
talking about you know the
rules they're willing to bend for the
things they care the most about because
arguably people attacking them probably
don't have the wrong
idea being that they're posing as
imperials you know
so yeah i love the sense of scope and
perspective that they brought in
especially
you know when bilber has that talk
directly about just the repercussions
and
all the different nasty ripples that
come out of these
imperial exploits you know it was it's
kind of interesting because
i know this is not a popular star wars
film but in the last jedi
the benicio del toro character dj had
some
kind of similar beliefs when it came to
republican empire you know and
mayfield kind of represents some of
those same beliefs but it's shown in a
much more visual representation here
especially when they're going through
the village
and saying like to them it's all the
same bottom line someone's ruling the
galaxy and there's order and stuff and
so i like that this
was wrapped up in like philosophical
beliefs
at the same time there was some sweet
[ __ ] in action
like that chase scene was really cool
like you talked about with uh i mean we
were talking about perspectives
thematically but i also thought in terms
of visually it did a really good job at
when they cut to the pirates and then
when you cut to dinjar and in the
stormtrooper outfit of capturing certain
moments of these scenes that are clearly
from his perspective the way they
they did all that with the combination
of cgi and stunt work it seems so
seamless oh yeah uh i was very impressed
with it i thought of
pirates of the caribbean dead man's
chest and that's in that sequence okay
and those are pirates are not they're
like our but those are pirates who are
hunting them down and there is sort of
this swashbuckling adventure vibe
yeah when they're going through the the
jungle terrain to try to get
the rhidonium across the across the
bridge you know it reminded me of a big
old mishmash of like yeah elements of
pirates elements of mad max just people
falling off
giant trucks and hitting wheels and then
just a classic you know western train
robbery set up
exactly yeah fighting people literally
off of instead of horses you know
little hover ships you know fighting
them off the train and trying to keep
the precious cargo safe perfectly
classic while also feeling perfectly
star wars you know the shootout scene
was really cool at the end too you gotta
see
cara dune and fenix sham work together
sniper rifling
but damn does boba fett look
fresh yes polished uh wow
he looks super fresh that polish
shine the second with that whatever that
like period tie fighter junkyard was at
the beginning and
then you see boba fett show about screen
like wow
since the last episode he's just been
working on the art
he's never looked this clean before
buffing it
who's been driving slave one
whoever's available because nate boba
he's in the back
tinkering with the armor and don't say
otherwise i stopped by
autozone uh so whether this is a little
personal note when they did have mayfeld
and uh tamora morrison on screen at the
same time they were both bald and i was
like huh
bill bird was in breaking bad and there
was a whole breaking ball thing going on
in my mind went there dude
breaking ball tribute it's an easter egg
it's an easter egg easter egg
new rock stars better mention it or else
they're frauds yeah well that's what
they do when they bring bill burr and
they have to bring everything about him
because i mean part of bill burr's
connection to star wars is talking crap
on star wars and it's half of what he
did
i feel like how do you see out of these
costumes these are really uncomfortable
i found them slightly distracting in the
first the first time he was around cause
i'm like
freaking bill burke but this time around
he blended in my mind does have to do a
little bit of work every time because i
am a big bill burr fan uh hey three b's
i am a huge bill burr fans i've seen all
the stand-up specials anytime he's on a
podcast or something or interviews i
i have to listen to it i think he's
hilarious of course i'm like
i'm aware it's bill burr i'm watching
but eventually he just
he slips right into it he's really
committed and he's actually a solid
actor and they think
he is a solid actor i mean king of
staten island people really praised his
work there and then here especially
like he brought gravitas to this role
and i
i love that he wasn't just going for the
joke he felt like a very human character
and
i thought he earned it you know in the
end they did even though
he went against the plan he earned it oh
yeah exactly
it was rewarding all the more because of
that i think too is the first season
it's like oh
cool fun character episode with famous
comedian and now it's like oh damn they
really legitimized him and gave
yeah they made me care for real about
the character of mayfield not just
oh it's fun to see bill burton and cara
dunes gonna get fired
i mean it's a small town i mean the
first the last episode she was
like i can't i don't know i'm not sure
you're sacked you're gonna get fired
she'll be fine
she'll be fine she'll be fine unless
you're real-life complicated
she gets her out of this and then of
course that ending note it's funny
i thought we'd see so much more moth
gideon this season i feel like he might
have had the same amount of screen time
so far that he had in the previous
season yeah but i think he's probably
gonna get a significant amount more
screen time
i don't think he's gonna die no i think
he i think he'll be around for season
three and they're gonna we're gonna see
a lot of him in season three but i love
that level of like
confidence that danjarin threw down and
how he just directly used
it might have been all the lines for
sure there's a few science sentences
there i'm like oh
i remember when gideon said that yeah
it's not for him to throw it back in his
face like that to
intimidate him now ah
very dangerous sexy latino mofo
oh and i was a little bit confused
it might have just been metaphorically
speaking because alderaan is
gone and he said man something doesn't
exist or something
was mayfield just implying that it's
just not what it once
was it doesn't mean anything anymore
it's abandoned
it's not blown up because when he was
talking about bo katan
yeah they just sounded like it was a
place that has just been forsaken
essentially
or is not what it once was because it's
freaking mandalore i think that if it
was actually like gone there would have
been some sentence acknowledging it
yeah yeah well i think the overall point
of what he was saying there basically is
just that you know you might revere this
thing but if you really look at it from
the outside as one of a whole bunch of
other
technologies you know that aren't as
prevalent as they used to be at the very
least
yeah yeah all right guys well are you
excited for the mayfeld show coming up
leave your thoughts down below what'd
you think of this episode
what are your predictions for how it's
going to end subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
please do hit the like button if you
enjoyed this video
last but not least
paul parenthesis pj parenthesis pj
parenthesis p that's what the p stands
for yeah parenthesis j
parenthesis parenthesis jimenez
nice so pj as we talk
regularly i know you're keeping up to
date with the mandalorian i'm glad
you've been enjoying this series as much
as you have been and i also know you're
very much
family oriented so i wanted to wish you
and your family
a merry christmas happy holidays
and i hope you have some great new
year's plans in mind but
hopefully this year for christmas you
get the presents
you've been hoping for which i believe
is a jar of peanuts ooh like a work with
that
yes a jar of peanuts because hey
peanuts are great they are uh great to
eat on their own you can mash them
charlie brown that's how it works oh
charlie brown
christmas what a movie to watch
pj it worked merry christmas you're
welcome that's your gift peanut jam